in a stunning new poll republican senate
majority leader
mitch mcconnell is losing to challenger
amy mcgrath
in his kentucky senate re-election race
now i'll give you the caveats in a
moment
but the fact that this is even close is
already a really big deal it's typically
not close at all
in kentucky for mitch mcconnell in his
re-elections there's a new poll
from rmg group and it has amy mcgrath up
41 to 40.
amy mcgrath as you may know is uh an air
force veteran
and challenging one of the uh one of the
longest sitting senators and the longest
ever
tenured senator out of kentucky now
what's very very interesting is that
the poll is 4140 in favor of amy mcgrath
it's within the margin of error a
statistical tie certainly
when people participating in the poll
are told
amy mcgrath favors congressional term
limits and mitch mcconnell opposes them
which is true
her support actually increases pretty
dramatically
but there are a lot of undecided still
in this poll
and there are certainly a fair number of
people supporting someone other than
mitch mcconnell or amy mcgrath so
when we typically talk about the senate
in 2020
and we think about what's the most
likely path that democrats could have to
taking control of the senate in 2020
we often go to arizona where mark kelly
is very much ahead of martha mcsally the
incumbent republican
we'll look at corey gardner republican
incumbent in colorado who
is well behind and may lose we think
about
susan collins in maine tom tillis in
north carolina maybe steve bullock in
montana there's a few others
i'm not talking about all of them but we
don't usually talk about mitch mcconnell
mitch mcconnell
has been one of the most effective
republican legislators in years he's
gotten
a ton of right-wing judges confirmed he
successfully
blocked barack obama's supreme court
pick merrick garland
holding that seat open for a year until
donald trump was inaugurated and
ultimately selected neil gorsuch that is
horrifying horrifying but if you are a
republican
that's a major accomplishment that
should have been barack obama's
selection
and mitch mcconnell was able to hold it
for donald trump disgusting but if
you're on their side
you love it it would be incredible
to remove mitch mcconnell and he's
currently down one now let me give you
the caveat
mitch mcconnell is down one but it's 41
to 40.
so statistically it's a tie and the
challenger
at some point is going to need to get to
50 or close to it amy mcgrath
is at 41. if she can't start getting to
45
48 closer to 50 typically
in these elections the undecideds and
the third party holdouts
as we get closer to election day are
going to break for the incumbent in this
case it's mitch mcconnell so
amy mcgrath's ceiling could be the 41
that she has right now which is not
going to be enough to win it but
it's a fight it's a fight anti-mcconnell
kentuckians
should get involved in this race it
would be a grace
if you're in a state that doesn't have a
hotly contested senate seat you could
get involved in phone banking
and fundraising for amy mcgrath
mcconnell has been in the u.s senate
longer than any other senator from
kentucky has ever been
mitch mcconnell went to the senate in
1985 the year after i was born mitch
mcconnell went to the senate
and mitch mcconnell is still in the
senate it's too much
it's too much he's got to go he's been a
senate majority leader for five years
since 2015 and he has left
a massive destruction in his wake and if
indeed mitch mcconnell loses
it would be a huge bellwether for how
the entire senate is going now you know
usually when we do analyses we say
here's how this one race is going
here's how this other race is going the
reality is that these things come in
waves
if the incumbent from 1985
republican majority leader is knocked
out in kentucky
a lot of these other races are likely to
go in the direction of democrats and we
will probably
if that happens have donald trump to
thank seats and states
that are rarely if ever in play for
democrats are now a fight
even forcing republicans to have to
spend money to defend them
is a victory because these are often
very easy to win
states and races for republicans so pick
a race
uh if it's in your state great if you're
in a state without a close election
find something nearby or something
you're interested in there is plenty to
be done and this being kentucky
i'm thinking about getting a nice bottle
of kentucky bourbon to have for election
night coverage and if mitch mcconnell
loses on november 3rd maybe we'll we'll
open that up
even though it will be a very big uphill
battle but by the way the the warning is
because this polling is close this piggy
backs on the earlier story about the
suppression we saw yesterday in georgia
because this election is close we should
expect that kentucky republicans are
going to go extra hard on the voter
suppression
and the other types of election fraud
tactics so we will likely need
extra margin if amy mcgrath is to defeat
mitch mcconnell
it's been happening this week in georgia
and elsewhere massive poll closures
creating very large weights and
disproportionately democratic areas
we know the tactics but we've got to
fight them okay
next week tuesday night 8 pm eastern we
will be having the second david pakman
show chess tournament
this is free to all this is not members
only there's no fee this is just free
it's just
uh building sportsmanship and
camaraderie
in a difficult time um so that'll be
tuesday june 16th at 8 00 pm eastern the
tournament will be on leaches.org
i'll have more info about that but put
it in your calendar i hope you'll play
we had 500 players
last time and i hope we do better than
that in the meantime make sure to let me
know what you think about this mcconnell
race on twitter
i am deep hackman on twitter one of our
sponsors is privacy.com they're giving
you five dollars when you sign up for
their completely
free service at privacy.com
pacman i've been using privacy for a
little over a year now you've heard me
talk about it before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something online or on
the phone
instead of actually using your real
credit card number the privacy app
and the browser plug-in let you give
each company
a randomized virtual credit card number
that you create out of thin air it'll
even autofill the card number with one
click
and the payment is taken out of your
checking account
without the merchant ever knowing your
real information so this allows you to
keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create
up to 12 of these virtual credit cards a
month you can set spending limits you
can freeze them
you can delete them anytime you want so
when you do this
it means you're not going to be charged
when you don't want to be because you
can destroy
the virtual card number right after
using it which for instance
i love using free trials because i know
i won't be charged when the trial is
over
if i use a virtual credit card number
you're keeping your identity private
by not telling companies who you are
you're keeping your bank
or credit card info protected against
data breaches and identity theft
and it's free there's no catch
whatsoever but if you want
privacy also offers a ten dollar a month
plan that gives you one percent cash
back and lets you create
36 credit cards a month and a 25
a month plan tailored more for small
businesses where you can create
60 card numbers a month and much more
but
definitely go ahead and at least get
started with the free plan you'll
protect your financial info companies
can't charge you unexpectedly and like i
said
you'll get five dollars to spend when
you sign up
at privacy.com slash pacman